well hello and welcome I'm Steven
Perloff the editor of the photo review
and before I start the introduction I
will remind you of several things we are
filming this evening Steven Spielberg
himself I believe I think I'm also to
remind you to turn off your cell phones
and lastly you will hold questions till
the end of Matthew's presentation and
when you ask a question wait for them to
bring a mic to you because if you just
shout it out they can't really hear you
well tell you just a bit about the photo
review since this is a commercial before
the main event the photo review is a
non-profit Journal of photography
founded in 1976 which means this is our
40th anniversary we published a
newsletter which lists photography
exhibitions throughout the mid-atlantic
region Philadelphia New York Washington
Delaware Maryland Virginia and news
about photography from around the world
we also have a journal that has
exhibition reviews book reviews essays
and publishes the winners of our annual
competition but most of you probably
know Matthew so I will just give a brief
introduction Matthew has had an interest
in abandoned site since he was a child
we won't go into the psychology of that
but all good but he started documenting
them a decade ago while researching the
decline of the state hospital system
after Matthew received his MFA from the
Rochester Institute of Technology his
Shanna's work in gallery shows across
the country lectured on abandoned spaces
and mental health history for numerous
institutions been profiled in various
publications and on various media
and his website abandoned America has
gained international attention and is
considered one of the leading
collections of images of abandoned
spaces on the Internet
well we're here today to launch
Matthew's latest book of abandon America
second volume and as you look through
these images both in print and in the
book you will see a very accomplished
eye in terms of creating a photograph
within a rectangle Matthews vision
really gets to the heart of the matter
in terms of composition in terms of
color and of course in terms of the
content and that's what's really
important about the work there are many
people who have and continue to
photograph abandoned spaces and you
might have a beautiful image of an
abstract pattern of paint on a wall or
an abandoned glove left on a factory
floor but what Matthew does is remind us
of the lives that once inhabited these
spaces the only thing that is constant
in our lives is change none of these
spaces industries homes hospitals was
necessarily meant to last forever nor
does anything particularly last forever
but it's how we treat these places what
we expect out of them and how we plan
for the institutions that succeed them
it's especially appropriate in this
political campaign season I grew up in
upstate Pennsylvania and coal mining
country the coal industry has been
disappearing for years despite what
politicians will say coal is not coming
back
there's nothing you can do to save it it
is a victim of improving technologies of
market forces that drive down the price
of call and certainly for the many
miners who are losing their jobs we have
to figure out how to retrain them and
get them to industries that need them
but for all those miners who had black
lung who were injured had friends family
members killed in the mines it's not
that bad a thing on one level same with
factory jobs we need to think about what
the future holds and how we can make
that happen and personally I think that
Matt's photographs really show us the
elegance of what has been but leaves us
with that question of what will follow
my pleasure to introduce Matthew
Christopher
[Applause]
hi everybody thank you for coming out
tonight I'm really grateful to have all
of you here means a lot to me that you'd
come out and sort of share this evening
with me so we excited to talk to you
about my new book before I do I just I
have several people to thank I mean I
have actually a million people to thank
but a few that will keep the evening you
know running on schedule I'd like to
thank my family and my lovely fiancee
Olivia both of whom have helped
tremendously with this event
I'd like to thank the sponsors of this
event those sponsors are entertaining
grace entertaining grace if you're
looking at you know the lovely set up
out there and the catering and all the
decorations and everything that is
entertaining grace so you can look up
entertaining grace online and if you
have any wonderful events that you would
like to have they're the ones to do it
the Athenaeum of philadelphia and
partners for sacred places also our
community partner the Gershman why
obviously I'd love to thank the photo
review and Steven Perloff for coming out
and being a part of this evening that is
really an honor to me the sites like art
blog and in liquid that help get the
word out about the event all of you who
have come out here supported the book
the work people who have reviewed the
book and you know people who are here to
share this evening with me also
Eric O'Hara and Danielle burrows who
both helped me quite a bit with editing
the book and c-span for being here
tonight with us especially especially
rich who held the door for us about 10
million times today as we were bringing
things in and out thank you rich so
anyway this is a pretty great night not
just in terms of the book being out and
finally done which I have to tell you
that is that is pretty great for me not
as some sort of you know big life
accomplishment but just just being
finished with it because it was a lot of
work but also this is the 10 year
anniversary of my website so my website
abandoned America
which is where we got the title for the
books that I have dismantling the dream
which is the current one and age of
consequences which was my first book
that's a late that is basically a
catalogue of all the different sites
that I've been to or at least as many of
them as I processed and have an added
online so I'm it's kind of a
never-ending thing that I'm building
usually in the beginning I like to give
people a little bit of an idea just to
give you some of the breadth of the
places that have been - this is an
entirely new collection of images so
we'll experience it together this is a
China plant that I've been to all of
those various forms there used to make
the plates and dishes they're quite
heavy that's why they're sinking through
the floor you're looking at Bethlehem
Steel's gas blowing room right there if
you go out to get Bethlehem Steel now
you can see the steel stacks and all the
restoration work that they did if you go
up on the Hoover Mason trestle you can
look down into this room but when I went
there in like 2008-2009 the whole
facility was was completely abandoned
this is Alcoa aluminum one of the
locations in my first book that's
Frederick Maryland this is the Fisher
Body plant in Detroit so if you ever see
body by Fisher stamped on your car
that's that's where they did it
apparently this is like 2008 ish when I
took this apparently a good chunk of the
facade of that fell off this is lime
quarry and Marietta Pennsylvania the
Hershey Chocolate Factory that one is
one that is really kind of a poignant
one for me because I spent a good
portion my youth growing up in Hershey
and my father worked there he didn't
work in the factory he worked in the IT
section but still you know really
integral to the identity of the town
they did build a newer facility so it's
not like they went bankrupt or something
but this is the iconic one that was you
know Milton Hershey's baby when he
founded it says the Pittsburgh
post-gazette one of the recent ones that
I photographed major urban newspaper
they moved their offices out into the
suburbs so basically this
facility which has these three-story
printing machines like this is being
dismantled as we speak this is Bell Labs
that's in my first book Bell Labs is the
place that you have to thank for a
myriad of technologies including
satellite microwave cellular technology
laser technology they're the ones who
developed a whole Dell horn which is
what they verified the Big Bang with
grant lace no longer looks like this but
at the time these were all Nottingham
looms that they had that were all
threaded with the lace that they were
making when it closed it was a really
wonderful room one of them remains and
it's not in very good condition LeBeau
brothers clothing Factory people
frequently ask me why there are so many
things left over in a case like this
with LeBeau you had thousands of coats
in there and the reason that the place
closed is because guys don't wear suit
jackets that much to work anymore so
they weren't doing the same business
they did if they are closed because of
debt then everything inside is more or
less cease to potentially pay off
debtors right coats are chump change to
a bank they don't really matter to them
this is Baltimore Gas and electrics
Westport generating station Westport
generating station was where they
consolidated all of their gas and
electric into one building at the time
it was the largest reinforced concrete
building in the world it was made out of
reinforced concrete so that if there was
a fire or anything blew up the whole
place wouldn't burn down power plants
and water stations Public Utilities
actually if some of the greatest
architecture that you'll ever see
they're gorgeous buildings which I
always think is really kind of
astonishing because they're places the
public really doesn't get to see and of
course they have areas like this this
sub-basement where you just have kind of
a steampunk nightmare of toxins you know
as is probably what that is so I've been
to a number of resort this resort for
example if you were to go over to the
other side of the hallway you would see
that the room on the other side of the
hall is actually in pretty good
condition you could put sheets on the
bed and you might not be able to tell it
from a regular hotel that is because
this side of the building has water
coming
and the other side is not this is
another resort that I've been to I'm
gonna have to confess that I've read the
name I haven't actually heard it spoken
Erik frame the guy who shot some of the
Pennsylvania State Troopers and then was
on the lam for a while they had a big
manhunt for him this Resort is where
they found him I I don't assume that he
slept on that bed because it doesn't
look all that safe that hotel was burned
by an arsonist that's in belafonte a
really gorgeous gorgeous building and
one of the things that I point out in my
other kind of my previous talk I have a
you know kind of previous presentation I
have a whole spiel on why abandoned
buildings will kill you so therefore you
should not go in them but I'm condensing
that this is all new stuff guys so right
here though I will point out that's a
hole in the stairs this whole stairway
is carbonized so really I mean there's a
very good chance at any point going up
that stairway you would just go right
through it and probably punch through
the one below it and then you know be in
a world of hurt beneath it so smart
people really don't go upstair ways I do
this is this is one of the many churches
that I've been to it's in quite good
condition and the thing about churches
that I think is really standout is that
they're kind of works of art I mean
they're built to be works of art whether
or not you share the faith or not of the
church doesn't matter as much to me
there I mean in Philadelphia in
particular they're an endangered species
but much more so in other cities as well
I mean this is in the Pittsburgh area
and you know the neighbors that are
around it are very worried about even
though they don't want to lose the
building they're very worried about
bricks falling off of it or you know
like a predator kidnapping somebody and
bringing them in there this building
also in the Pittsburgh area is the Holy
Trinity Church and the whole middle
section of that church just recently
collapsed and they actually had to
evacuate portions of the neighborhood
around it because they were worried
essentially about the whole front of the
building collapse
hang on to them which would have been
pretty bad this is st. boniface Church
in Philadelphia one of the churches in
my first book st. Boniface I was
actually really lucky Chris stock of
Philadelphia salvage got me into this
building as they were demolishing it I
had been trying to get in there for five
years five years and I couldn't I
couldn't get ahold of anybody and so I
got in at this last minute well they
were right in the middle they had ripped
the apse off of the building and and
this was essentially what was left this
is another church that have been to this
one right here the interesting thing
about that is that there is a small fire
you can actually see the remains of it
in the lower left-hand corner and it
didn't do a lot of structural damage but
it did do a lot of soot damage so the
whole church aside from being really
really dark because of the windows you
know there being a lack of light in it
also was sort of pitch black so it had
this really nightmarish kind of feel to
it very surreal I have been to a good
many homes in fact so many abandoned
homes that if I had a dollar for each of
them I could probably stop writing books
and just be at home playing xbox right
now it'd be great the homes that have
been - sometimes I mean there are really
parts of whole neighborhoods like this
one this was a miners village that yes
that horse is real by the way I did not
digitally insert that horse if I did he
probably would be in front of the tree
but anyway this I mean it's an owned
area a guy is bought it and really wants
to kind of bring it back to some sort of
like Williamsburg s kind of historic
village I don't know whether that's
gonna succeed or not but it was
definitely very interesting because you
had a bunch of horses wandering around
that I was not supposed to pet and yet
came up like right in my face so I was
kind of like oh I must not pet you horse
don't bite me some of the homes are full
of people's items in them and you know I
think homes of all places really give
you the most instrument intimate
portrait of who people are so you know
you find these effects that are there
and sometimes they
really tell you you know little secrets
about people that I think are
interesting and that's one of the things
in my work that's really important is
kind of trying to find those little
stories that people have you know some
of the homes are in a quite good
condition like I said they can be in
whole neighborhoods this neighborhood
right here many of the homes recently
burned in an arson which is
unfortunately something you kind of see
happen again and again and abandoned
places so I don't know if this home in
particular is gone but it's pretty
likely schools I've been to a quite a
few schools I think schools are
sometimes the the most difficult
personally I'll talk a little bit more
about that later but this school you
know they really represent an investment
of the community and they're a source of
pride and they mean a lot to people and
one thing that I sort of talked about
too is that you know you basically when
you're you know the school that you went
to if you were to go back to that school
now you might have all sorts of memories
charred loose oh that was that weird kid
that sat next to me that always would
like throw his pencil at me or you
remember when the teacher said this one
thing so we really have these
connections to buildings that when
they're gone in a way it's kind of
erasing a part of our own identity this
building luckily is it's a McKissack and
associates a Harrisburg based firm has
purchased this building and are turning
it into homes it's in Chambersburg so we
got a chance to photograph that right
before they started doing it which is
pretty neat I always think this one you
know that really stands out to me if I
had to sum up my feelings on abandoned
schools and the saying that would
probably be pretty close you know where
there is no vision the people perish for
those of you with poor eyesight like me
again some of the buildings are in
really atrocious condition be pretty
date and can be pretty dangerous one
thing that you'll notice and this is in
this classroom the whole floor is
falling in but part of the reason is
because as tongue-and-groove
construction you can see if you look
over on this side right here see where
the board's would fit into the wall
water collects in that area the board's
wrought around that area faster
so when they go they can go bit by bit
like this or they can just pancake down
onto the next floor and then on the
floor beneath that in which case you
were again in a world of hurt if you're
standing on them this is north east
manual training school also known as
Julie de Burgos also known as Thomas a
Edison High School in Philadelphia that
was really also a point of pride for the
city people like Herbert Hoover Albert
Einstein Babe Ruth Amelia Earhart that
came and spoke they're a really
prestigious school recently torn down it
is going to be a parking lot in a dollar
store I believe so
just as we build things with purpose so
too do we lose them you know that says
things about who we are as well some
other institutions that I've been to
would include this orphanage Pennhurst
state school and Hospital often
erroneously referred to as Pennhurst
asylum it's not an asylum
never was asylums were for people with
mental illness institutions were for
people with physical and developmental
disabilities Pennhurst was kind of known
as as one of the ones that was you know
pretty pretty well known for its neglect
and the abuses that went on there
there's a really kind of chilling
documentary that you can watch on it
called suffer the little children that
was really good some of the other places
such as Greystone Park Psychiatric
Center in Jersey that was recently torn
down by good old Chris Christie even
though there were some really good reuse
plans that they could have had that
would have benefited the community a lot
more than just ripping it down a lot of
times - people will say oh well you know
there's terrible memories in these
places like these solitary cells for
example you can see the little food
slots under the door when people say
well you know it's such a bleak history
or whatever maybe we should just tear it
down and start again which i think is
just ridiculously wasteful and you know
that sort of superstitious thinking
should not define what we do with our
historic architecture I believe but you
know other buildings like this State
Hospital are in much much worse
condition I always am kind of
shock that I don't see photographer
skeletons you know laying around impaled
on the punji pit right there because
this place is you know this is like on
the third or fourth floor of this
building and you know you're probably up
above what that is you know in the
previous picture it's not like directly
one-to-one correlation there but the
point is that it's it's an extremely
deadly building this is Ellis Island
this is the Ellis Island for those of
you who've been there there's a museum
on it it's a u-shape it used to be that
the whole place was abandoned Lee
Iacocca in the 80s invested in building
the museum on the one side and the
center where the immigrants came in
still abandoned and then on the far side
they had the communicable disease
hospital which we actually was supposed
to be really good but if you came to
America and you had scarlet fever
rubella you know typhoid they would send
you over there you would they would
either send you home
where you'd go there you'd get treatment
and then you'd go into the community or
you die and you'd wind up in the autopsy
theater right here you can see these old
and this is kind of even pre
refrigerated morgue daze right there
with the the wood slabs and everything
this hospital the thing that I think is
kind of crazy about that is the patterns
that there was a fire in this place so
those patterns are made by water
dripping down the wall and from the
ceiling this is a retirement home it's
been to quite a few tuberculosis
sanatorium such as this one or this one
which is where they actually cured TB
there are people that are contentious
out there believe it or no that will say
hey they haven't completely cured TB
there's multi drug-resistant strains of
it I know but this is the reason that
one in five people that you know haven't
died of it because they developed the
treatment for it they kept it from
wiping out the astronomical numbers of
people that it had been wiping about
since prehistoric times it did such a
great job that it put itself out of
business essentially which to me is kind
of a shameful thing I mean could you
imagine if you know we had a hospital
and they cured cancer I mean just all of
it all the various strains and we said
okay well we don't really need that
place anymore and just left it fall into
disrepair that would actually be you
know less of a slight I think in this
place
prisons this is Holmesburg prison in
Philadelphia that too late the last
place is in my first book I have a lot
of horror stories that I can tell you
guys about it but time so this building
right here is a prison in Caldwell New
Jersey and the thing about this one was
that there are a lot of people that will
view these pictures and you know when I
talk about the horrible conditions that
were in here because I can't even tell
you I mean again like that's in the
first book take a look at that the
conditions that were recorded than there
were so bad that if you were to think of
what hell would be like it probably
would be better than that so it was so
overcrowded they didn't have trained
staff they didn't have medications for
people there were bugs there was no
space for anyone there was disgusting
water pouring from the ceilings that you
know caused sores and people because it
was so filthy pieces of the building
were falling apart onto people I could
go on and on and on about this and there
are a lot of people out there that'll be
like well if you can't do the crime
don't do the time but the thing about
this is that a number of the people that
were in here hadn't even been convicted
they just couldn't pay their bond so
this prison and again I had a bit of a
longer thing where I talked about it
last time but you know I am not very
superstitious people always ask me about
ghosts no I haven't seen ghosts
I'll just throw that right out there I I
have an active imagination I think a
number of the places are pretty spooky I
can picture all sorts of creepy monsters
in them while I'm there by myself taking
pictures but I've never seen any thank
the Lord this place the reason that
stands out is that in this prison it was
a on an active campus for another prison
this used to be where the the criminally
insane were and then they moved them to
a newer facility so the guy who was
taking me around this was one of the
people who work at the other one and he
was really creeped out by this place he
was really like you know there are
ghosts in this place here's some stories
that people have told me about the
ghosts that haunt this place and at a
certain point it was kind of like well
you know I don't mean to be
disrespectful or and
thing but you work with criminally
insane people that's a scary day to me
you know like I'll take the haunted
building over the building that is full
of actual criminally insane people this
building also one of the creepier ones I
think prisons are really about the
creepiest of the buildings the thing
that was really eerie about this one was
there were a lot of people that were
living in it still a lot a lot of people
and so whereas with many buildings you
have kind of heightened senses and you
you know you're like oh what's that a
branch against the window or a pigeon
flutters and it makes you hop in this
place you'd be like what's that over
there oh it's a dude just watching me
across the way and then he'd kind of
meld off in the shadows in five or ten
minutes later you'd see somebody else on
one of the other levels watching you
that was a different person constantly
all throughout the time I was there I do
not exaggerate it was that was a really
really eerie place to be this prison the
thing that I had sort of put in here
that I thought was interesting about
that one was there's a whole bunch of
just scrawls all over the walls and the
solitary cells in this I actually had
one that was a whole huge wall of just
insane ramblings but there were also a
lot of large prominent curse words on it
so I figured because c-span is here with
us tonight I would spare you all but the
thing that really did that I think was
the eeriest of all of them I can share
with you is this this was on an active
campus - nobody else came into this
building except for the people that were
a part of the prison system this is in
the solitary cells I have to imagine
they did not like give them finger
paints or anything you know I don't know
what they rode that almost makes it a
little easier you know not knowing what
it is and just seeing a little bit of
bloody scrawl left on the wall some of
the prisons and many of the other
buildings that go into her in quite good
condition sometimes people will condemn
contests whether they're actually
abandoned based on like whether the
lights are on or not such as this place
where the electricity is still there but
you know I didn't just ask everybody to
please go to their cells
so theaters I've been to a number of
theaters I think they're right up there
with churches in terms of scope and
scale for those of you that are of my
generation and younger I think you know
we're seeing less and less of these
places they're much more rare especially
something like this one I mean granted
you know in its condition sure but back
in the day I mean this is a multi
balcony theater and yes they actually
are that steep so when you're up at the
top it was really kind of
vertigo-inducing to see like five floors
down to the stage some of the oddball
ones an aquarium Philadelphia Ice House
was not abandoned caught fire was
abandoned then for about a week this all
was from the the water that the
firefighters sprayed on it they tore it
down shortly thereafter enchanted forest
in Ellicott City a bank that has been
converted to a bookstore and then
abandoned again so if any of you were
bookworms and introverts like me this
seems like this would be a pretty cool
place to have this is a Cleveland osanic
temple in Cleveland this is an Elks
Lodge that I went to another question I
frequently get is how I find these
places so to preempt that I'm going to
tell you it's usually research
networking and dumb luck this was a dumb
luck place I just stumbled across it as
I was driving and all the doors were
open so I went in and it was very creepy
nobody really knew I was there this room
was a lot darker then even this picture
gives you an idea of that's at the top
of the building you know pieces the roof
hanging off like that shaft of light
coming in at the other end of the room
little thing in the wall there and I was
kind of squinting at it like you know
what could that be what is that thing
over there happy nightmares guys
[Music]
it's even worse when you're in a creepy
abandoned building and that's the thing
across the room and then when you see it
right is you're kind of piecing together
and your brain is processing it's like
some sort of 1800s out terminator that
your foot goes through the floor and so
like any sane person I stayed and
photographed the place for the rest of
the day which is good because when I
came back three months later it was
ripped in half the building they were
tearing it down since a Marg aerospace
maintenance and reclamation group in
Tucson Arizona that's where all the
branches of all the service services
store their planes from the Coast Guard
to the US Air Force it is very active
facility don't do like you know that
movie can't buy me love and try and
sneak in there don't do that because
there are plenty of people with rifles
wandering around that will ask you what
you're doing so now I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about the book now that
we've gone through the fact that I've
been to a great variety of places this
is the fall slide hotel I figured I'd
start off with this one the fall side
started as Treadway hotel in 1957 and
Niagara Falls New York and one of the
things that I really look for in these
places and it's really important to me
particularly as I'm writing about them
for the book is not just what is the
story of this particular place but what
is sort of if that's a microcosm what is
the macrocosm that it says something
about so in this case it really is
tourism in Niagara Falls tourism is
something that has gone back centuries I
mean people you know settlers have
recognized the scenic beauty of that
area for a long time but also for
centuries there's been this tug of war
with the industries in the area and so
as this was being built it was also a
time when the industries were pretty
much unregulated they were kind of just
dumping things into the the Niagara
Falls itself a lot of toxins and and
whatnot and there is also this huge
influx of people because there's you
know there's free electricity from the
water so they're building this huge new
hydroelectric electric dam because the
other one collapsed into the the Falls
so there's all these people coming into
the town all this all this industry all
this kind of lack of regulation also
then a lot of urban renewal in that
period too so as you go into like the
60s they sort of raised the whole
downtown they built this it will advise
Robert Moses State Parkway that even the
mayor described is basically a Chinese
wall separating the town from the thing
that people came to see in the town so
this place did very well for a while it
was this is the circle it was the place
to you know kind of be seen a lot of
politicians came here in fact a JFK when
he was stumping came and delivered his
speech in front of this building and as
the years went on it changed owners it
became it was the the Treadway in the
beginning then it was the parkway then
it became a Ramada Inn then a Days Inn
then it eventually wound up as the fall
side so anyway the way this kind of
parallels the town is that really the
tourism part started taking a big hit
right as the industries also started
leaving so you had scenarios like the
Love Canal situation which I really had
very little idea of just how
apocalyptically awful that was for the
people that lived in that area I mean
you had people's swimming pools in their
backyard coming on board in pools of
chemicals and chemicals seeping into the
people's basements and kids going out to
play in the playground and getting
chemical burns and things like that so
you imagine if you're coming in to
basically to go for your honeymoon let's
say and to see the Falls and you first
come in through all the husks of the old
industrial buildings and then you come
into a town that has blooms of oil in
the water and open lagoons of chemicals
and things like that it really wasn't a
sight that you wanted to see also then a
lot of the people started leaving the
town as the the construction projects
were finished so you lost a good amount
of the population you lost the
industries that were keeping the town
afloat and then the ripples from the
industry really started hurting the
tourism so places like this really
struggled after a while and essentially
you
the the hotel closed in 2013 and at that
point it was already pretty kind of like
bed condition there are still some
online reviews floating around about it
that had all sorts of fun awful stories
about people going and staying in this
hotel and how bad it was thing about
this place is that I don't really some
of the places that I go to I think are
really architectural II and historically
significant I don't necessarily think
this is like an architectural jewel that
the area can't do without the fact is
right now that there's an investor that
is torn down the majority of the
building and is going to basically it
has has built another hotel
incorporating a little bit of it but on
that area and actually in that sense it
also symbolizes the overall fortunes of
the area and what I mean by that is that
you know it has new investors there are
new people that are building hotels in
it this guy who is built it is somebody
with a good deal of money and a lot of a
great track record of kind of picking
the trends of where areas are at he's
not a gambler as what I'm trying to say
so the fact that he's investing in this
community and also the other great thing
is the Robert State Moses Robert Moses
State Parkway is getting torn down and
they're going to be building basically
like a kind of pedestrian park sort of
thing there so it's actually going to be
a lot nicer when you go up there but
anyway like I said I kind of been
looking for those things that tell a
larger story than just the one place
right in this case I think you know
there's that parallel between the
fortunes of the the community in Niagara
Falls Taunton State Hospital Taunton
State Hospital I had I had to put on
asylum and I had to this Asylum was
opened in 1918 54 to relieve
overcrowding at Worcester State Hospital
it was basically I believe the the fifth
hospital to be built on the Thomas
Kirkbride plan which was really popular
at the time for these places and the
reason that this was really significant
to me was that honestly I mean I
started I started all of this as
somebody who worked in the mental health
field I worked in a private inpatient
facility and you know which basically is
the you know the kind of be the
stepchild I guess if you will of the
asylum system you know it's the
privatized version of it and I got
really interested in what it was that
made the asylums important and unique
and interesting and so I just read and
read and read and read about them and I
kept hearing about one called by Barry
that their Philadelphia State Hospital
that had a really uniquely terrible
history and so I went there and that's a
whole long story for another
presentation but basically these places
were what really got me interested in
abandoned buildings I started going to
other asylums I started then from the
asylums I found schools and factories
and all the other things I showed you
earlier
Taunton obviously is not Philadelphia
State Hospital but I think some of the
things that it shows it has that sort of
dichotomy that a lot of those places do
you have this really absolutely elegant
and gorgeous architecture that I think
symbolizes the commitment that people
had to caring for the less the less
fortunate I mean when these places were
built when Dorothea Dix was going around
in campaigning for the the state
hospitals to be created she wanted
people that were mentally ill to not
have to be in the streets and poor
houses and prisons and locked up in
their relatives attics and and this was
something where there was a lot of
idealism and ambition involved you know
when they were building them there was
something that towns were really proud
of they petitioned for them Taunton
petitioned for this place they had you
know postcards that you would send out
to people hey look at this grand
institution we had that defines our town
right but then as the years went on
underfunding overcrowding and
understaffing really became problems in
many of the places also there's you know
there's a number of things that again I
don't have enough time to go into all
the factors but you know one of the
things is the rise of eugenics which is
kind of you know the the seedling that
the final solution grew out of so this
is basically people with inferior gene
reproduce and then drag down the rest of
society so we should put them in places
like this and remove them you know that
was that was the predominant thinking
that came in the asylums and the other
thing too is that you know we have this
kind of view that oh its people that
were crazy or if we're nicer than to put
it that way we would say mentally ill
you know but really that's that's a
fluid kind of definition I mean there
are all sorts of things that people
would be committed for Lou Reed I
believe was committed to an asylum for
being homosexual you know if you were
too effeminate as a guy or too masculine
as a woman if your husband wanted to
cheat on you but he didn't want the
disgrace of trying to divorce you if
your brother wanted your land I mean
there are so many different reasons one
of the ones that I think stood out the
most to me
was a guy who is a Turkish immigrant and
just people didn't understand him
because he spoke Turkish so he spent his
life in an institution or an asylum
there's another one actually where it
was one of the reasons for somebody
being committed to tonton was loss of
interest in house work you know which is
you know in a way I mean it is it is
very funny but at the same time not so
much so if you're that person so these
are real people's stories these people
were were put into these places often
for their whole lives and forgotten
you know and so the thing about taunton
is and and the asylums in general or
those are the places that really I guess
kind of awakened me to feeling like you
know these are these are places that
were rarely photographed when they were
operational they're rarely photographed
after they were operational and yet
there's a lot of stories that need to be
told and they're just being left to fall
apart like this you know this is the
kind of demolition by neglect principal
Long Beach Long Beach moving along to
the next chapter is basically a
community in Connecticut and it's sort
of hard to describe
exactly what happened to this community
of sort of beach cottages unless you see
a map so basically on this map you'll
see this here is Long Beach this was
Pleasure Beach where they had a amused
park right up here you have Bridgeport
right down here you have Stratford and
all along here you have Long Beach right
so basically the deal with Long Beach is
it is a peninsula the only access that
you had to those cottages or to Pleasure
Beach was via this bridge that was built
up here because Stratford refused to
make a road through here so there's this
long and kind of contentious history
between Stratford and the long beach
cottages it seems like there was a lot
of animosity in the town towards the
cottages and a number of times it seemed
like they were the chafing was because
they did not want to provide them
services that taxpayers kind of normally
get you know I mean they were taxpayers
as well and in fact they were leasing
the property that they were on to for
very low amounts but they had built
their houses on it so anyway the bridge
that went over from pleasure Beach had
had several fires as the years went on
it got very rickety and part of the
reason why it was so easy to catch fire
was this substance called creosote that
was waterproofing but also is very
flammable so anyway a number of times
there were fires it was one of those
things where there was kind of you know
a lot of talk about what are we gonna do
are we gonna you know this bridge is
really rickety we keep having to dump
money into it etc etc well in 1996 the
the final fire that really took the
bridge out occurred and at this point
you had it was on a weekend it was on
Father's Day actually you had all these
people that were stranded in their homes
with their visitors that had come over
for the weekend and they had no bridge
to get off the island anymore and so
eventually they you know they brought
barges up and they took the people off
but it led to a greater question which
is how do you get to your homes now if
the bridge that you got out there on is
no longer there and Stratford's no
longer going is is not going to let you
build a bridge so these people basically
had two options they could go on a boat
to this rickety old dock or they could
walk the better part of a mile along
that sandbar so one of the things that I
really tried to do in this book was do
more interviews with people that were
directly involved with these places so
it's not just my voice and one of the
stories that I think was particularly
heartbreaking that I heard about was
this girl whose grandparents lived there
and these are people that were her dad
was a retired leave use like a municipal
worker and her mom was a factory worker
some of the other places like this place
in particular was a retired teachers
house so they're not people that are on
like their eighth home or anything that
are living there these are little plots
of land that they're running on the
cheap and then they built a little
vacation home on and she talked about
how after the fire occurred you know
they basically had her whole family took
wagons and dragged him along this
sandbar until they got to the the
cottages and filled it up with whatever
mementos they could fit in the wagons
and then had dragged them back along the
beaches until they got to their car we
all have this idea of a social contract
if the electricity goes out if the
plumbing break somebody's going to come
in and fix it right well this is what
happens when they dull this is what
happens when that social contract is
violated and we also like to think well
you know what if that happened to us at
least other people would help us out and
I hate to you know give the sort of the
the nihilists among us fuel but they
really don't they people came out and
eluded the cottages set them on fire and
it was really kind of an awful situation
I think the thing that I really felt
when I was here some places are really
peaceful some places are really
beautiful some are really scary some are
really sad this one made me really angry
you know because they're people's homes
and it was just so disrespectful that
people were coming in and treating them
that way when they had already got
kicked so hard by just sort of fate in
the town so Randall Park mall and again
you know I based on time there's a lot
more interesting stuff but you know I'm
just kind of trying to give you an
overview of some of these places Randall
Park mall was the largest mall that was
ever built at the time that it was you
know that they did construction on it it
was equipped shortly after that by Mall
of America but anyway this is in
and ol park or I'm sorry North Randell
Ohio and North Randell is basically a
town that used to have some racetracks
in it fairly small town I think it's
about 1,500 people when they built this
place this mall at its peak had 5,000
people visiting it today as both workers
and staff there were 9,000 parking
spaces in that that parking lot so when
I went there it's been out of business
and it had some really interesting kind
of gems like this which was the the
theater that had originally opened with
it and basically the theater was kind of
walled off in a way I mean it was a
men's clothing store that took over the
front of it and used some of the areas
as storage but these old shotgun
theaters were just left there and nobody
had really gone in them until you know
this point where I was there which was
with the the permission of the company
that owned it and they were demolishing
it at the time so the significance of
Randall Park mall you know it was really
not only a big part of the area's
economy but also I mean it was kind of
like the it became the entire identity
of the town like North Randall's logo
was these shopping bags you know and so
the thing that happens with them all
like this and actually one of the
reasons that you're seeing a lot of
malls falter right now is if you think
about it branding you know if a mall
starts to go downhill if it starts to
get a reputation for crime and I think
there were really two reasons why this
got a poor reputation one three one
reason was that a newer mall opened up
in another area and that started
attracting the upscale clientele to was
that there was actually I think some you
know deserved reputation for crime there
was the interstate was right next to it
and you have this huge parking lot
that's extraordinarily hard to police so
car theft happened quite a bit in the
parking lot you could just pull a car
from the parking lot and drive off the
guy who invented if any of you guys
remember the club that Auto Protection
thing the club was invented by a guy
whose father-in-law's car was stolen
from this parking lot
so there there was some merit to that
but there also was a lot of bigotry in
the community and you still kind of see
that now when you hear people talking
about the mall and it's it's a pretty
ugly honestly I mean for example one
thing that people will talk about when
they talk about the crime in the area
was this supposed race riot that
happened at the mall I'll be honest with
you I couldn't find anything about the
race riot I couldn't like I found plenty
of people talking about a race riot and
recollecting that a race riot happened
but as far as actual like newspaper
evidence or coverage of this nothing the
one thing that I did find in that time
period was a balloon popped
and some huge flock of kids thought it
was a gunshot and they ran to the other
end of the mall so you know this is
pre-internet days where you're kind of
playing the telephone game with people a
bit so I'm really wondering if that
event didn't somehow turn into that you
know and that people were very
uncomfortable with the fact you know you
have these these sort of white suburban
night shoppers going out there and
they're not the only ones there at the
mall so unfortunately like I said it was
really kind of some of these situations
are pretty ugly and and when you look at
the perception that people had of the
place being safe it doesn't seem to
quite jive up with what the actual area
was I mean even the the police chief in
the area said that it was no more or
less safe than any other mall but
perceptions everything branding is
everything you know so if you start to
get a reputation as being unsafe people
aren't going to come out and the other
thing about them all is if you start
financially struggling unlike say a
strip mall where you can like demolish
an area and build something else and
call it a new name or whatever you just
have dead stores like I don't know if
any of you guys have ever been to a mall
that's sagging and you're like wow
there's a subway and then the whole rest
of the wing is it's it's kind of creepy
in a way right you know and so you
entered this death spiral and the bigger
a mall is the harder it is I think
really for it to get out of that so at
the end you really have some of these
comical and awful stories
some of them both at the same time you
know like in the end days they had you
know people that got and there was a
lawsuit over a the Easter rabbit got in
a fight with one of the patrons as did
one of Santa's helpers at one of the
points but then there was another really
ugly story where a guy who is one of the
Dillards actually had a couple really
ugly stories but the one was a guy was a
security guard at Dillard's and he there
was an alleged shoplifter and to make a
long story short he basically sort of
picked the guy up and just threw him
right on his head on the concrete and he
died shortly after that and so you had
this towards the end you really did have
these kind of these situations that were
happening where it was kind of a
frightening place to be but yet there's
still a lot of people that really
remember this place fondly and up until
its final days it really had become kind
of a home for a lot of small businesses
too so I think it's you know easy to
kind of look at a place like this and
only see one thing that's good or bad
about it and and kind of run with that
but this by the way is one of the areas
this is a little bit of a side tangent
this is one of the areas it was a one of
two restaurants where they walled it off
in like the 70s the late 70s and they
were only discovered when they toured
open so if you're ever walking around
like King of Prussia Mall or whatever
and you see a whole stretch where it's
just drywall you know and kind of think
to yourself maybe there's something
behind there but anyway you know this
mall I think represents sort of the era
of mega consumerism you know and again
this this idea in the book overall
dismantling the dream you know refers to
the American Dream and kind of the
failures that have happened and what
that says about us is the people so you
know you look at the shopping malls they
really had a very short life span I mean
this place was born and died younger
than I am so the game farm the game farm
the Catskill Game Farm is a
basically a very well-known place if
you've gone there it's funny the the
current owner of it says you know
basically if you went to the catskill
geng farm when you were a kid or took
your family there you're like oh my god
it's the cats go game for him I can't
believe it you know and if you're
somebody else you have no idea who it
was but it was very significant to a lot
of people they basically started taking
guests in in 1945 and started as a
private collection of animals was this
guy named Lynda Mann basically was
collecting them in 1945 he had so much
demand for people to come in that he
opened it as a park and it just blew up
I mean you had the baby boomer children
he had this kind of era of day trips and
weekend trips and tourism that area and
the Catskills was really hot at that
point so people were going up there and
taking their kiddos and loading them in
the car and going up to this park where
they could take them to you know this
that one of the the key things and they
had a ton of exotic animals Lindemann
really believed in conservation you know
so he would go to areas where there were
endangered species of animals and would
basically bring them in and they had a
breeding ground where they would try and
breed them really loved animals but the
thing that was really popular about it
was that the kids could go into this
feeding ground area and pet the you know
basically be right up with the deer and
the sheep and the goats and stuff like
that and feed them out of baby bottles
and it was really kind of a sweet thing
and for a long time it really went well
and then basically it was a Lindemann
sold it to his daughter Cathy Schulze in
1989 and that was kind of where things
started to unravel a bit Cathy Schulze
was married to a guy with connections to
exotic animal trading in Texas that was
kind of his his business and so he he
basically a lot of the people that were
buying the exotic animals at that time
learn what's called canned hunts and if
you don't know what canned hunts are
that's probably good I'm sorry to be the
guy to tell you that you know human
nature is so bad but basically it
beware you know say you have those
animals that grew up and are no longer
cute you know and so they get sold to
somebody use a hunter but that hunter is
too lazy to go around and chase them
down in the woods or anything like that
they basically had these animals and
little pens and sometimes drugged and
the person would sort of drive up to
them in a jeep and execute them
point-blank and then put their head on
the wall and tell their friends about
this crazy adventure story they had
where they caught them there's really
pretty hideous and so as this was coming
out other zoos are starting to distance
themselves from the catskill game farm
like the San Diego Zoo I recall said
they weren't going to have anything to
do with them anymore and this really
became problematic for their image and
also I mean that era of first of all the
Catskills was was dying at that point as
a as an attraction for people so they
weren't getting the amount of people in
that way the idea of like a chain link
sue was a little outdated so even though
people had gone there for generations
and also I mean it really just seems
like Cathy and her kids were and all
that invested in it you know I mean
that's speculation but you really do
hear in the end about them not bringing
new animals in about the animals looking
like they're unhappy and and not all
that great of condition so anyway when
the zoo closed there was this by the way
is the the owners house in the game farm
when the zoo closed there is this really
kind of boiled over and so there were a
lot of people that were really trying to
save these animals from being sold off
to canned hunts and one of the really
neat stories is I don't know if you guys
are familiar with Mark Ecko the clothing
designer but he actually his logo is a
rhinoceros so they basically sort of
appealed to him and he wound up
purchasing two of the rhinoceroses from
somebody who was going to use them for a
canned hunt and he put them in a
sanctuary with like a web cam so people
could watch them as they lived out the
rest of their rhinoceros lives you know
which was really pretty terrific of them
so next time you're in the store and you
see Marc Ecko clothes you know he's a
good guy to the leap ah oh and one other
thing I'd like to throw out there with
the game farm though is just that
basically the game farm is now currently
owned by a couple that are really
terrific and are hoping to turn it into
like a bed-and-breakfast in an RV park
and everything and we're very nice to
not only let me come up there but also
gave a lot of information for the book
as well I'm gonna skip through the Lee
Plaza Hotel because I'm not sure where
we're at for time here I'll tell you
just a little bit Lee Plaza Hotel was
basically built when Detroit was booming
and you know Detroit was not in the top
10 list of cities in the US in 1900 but
by 1930 it seemed like it was going to
take the number 3 spot from Philly and
almost as soon as it was built it went
into all sorts of sort of contentious
legal problems and started to go
downhill it was bankrupt fairly quickly
so after that the city took it over they
turned it into a retirement home for a
while and then it was closed and at this
point it was closed in 1997 so at this
point it's kind of in pretty rough
condition but there are a lot of sort of
parallels there to the boom of Detroit
and then the you know the kind of
downfall of its economy and the
hemorrhaging of both jobs and citizens
Forest Haven was one of the ones that
was really important to me in this book
probably one of the most awful stories
that I've ever read it was sort of like
the more I read about it the more
terrible it was Forest Haven was a
facility that replaced the Washington
home for colored idiots was the name of
the place so it was built in 1925 and it
was essentially because the people in DC
didn't want those people in their
neighborhood I mean that that was it
really
so they built this place kind of out in
a rural setting it was supposed to be
it's an institution so an institution
would be for people with physical and
developmental disabilities and it was
supposed to be I think a pretty
progressive facility it was supposed to
be a place where you know people would
get training and medical care that they
needed and things like that but by the
time it was closed it was called the
deadliest known example
institutional neglect in American
history by the investigating attorney
one of the big problems that they had in
this place and oh my god there were many
one of the big problems they had was due
to improper feeding which is basically
you know you can blame the staff for
that but they're given eight people to
feed in the time that they could
adequately feed one and no training on
how to properly feed them so you have
situations where the one guy was talking
about his son in there where they were
pouring baby food down his throat until
it came out his nose while he was laying
down if you feed people while they're
laying down particularly in such a
manner one of the things that can happen
is they get aspirational pneumonia which
is where they ingested into their lungs
and then you know basically they get
infection or choked to death it's really
horrible but there are a lot of problems
like these in fact this is one of the
things one of the places where I
actually could not condense all of the
awful stories that I found into a
chapter you know I had it was like you
know there were certain points where I
was like I think I've made the point on
this you know I have to move on but you
know these are these are real people
that are there these are these are
people that are confined and are
basically getting really substandard
care it was it was really kind of
hideous
and the other thing too about the
aspirational pneumonia was that the
there's a point where somebody went to a
judge and said hey all these people are
dying of aspirational pneumonia we'd
like earmark about $25,000 for training
for people so that we can teach them how
to properly feed the residents so that
this doesn't happen and the judge
basically said I mean not basically he
actually said well they're mentally
[ __ ] so they're probably not that
healthy anyway it's really kind of a
horrific thing and I think the important
thing is when you see these places and
the actuality of them and you understand
that it's not like a legend or a ghost
story or whatever I mean these are real
people in this place these are real
lives that were lost the thing that
really stood out to me was and there
were a lot of really kind of unsettling
experiences but the one was when I was
in the morgue of this place
and there's all this shmoo and the floor
from the drop ceilings that have fallen
down there and you know paint and mud
and all that and as I was walking around
them I saw that there was a little pair
of glasses on the floor and then I
looked and I saw another one and I saw
another one now I was like well there's
a whole lot of little glasses on the
floor and these probably belong to dead
kids you know they I mean it was just so
many so many issues but yet again you
know you think of it you think of these
people coming to this place with their
suitcases and things and this very well
could have been the last place that they
wound up you know they may well not
really have seen the whole rest of the
world after that very much so and oh one
other thing too is that we like to pat
ourselves in the back and say well this
place closed so we're doing so much
better now we have people in community
facilities but actually the community
facilities really were pretty
substandard too and there was quite a
bit in that you know and as well the one
thing that it will kind of point out is
you know just to not leave it on a
completely horrible note is that the one
moment of levity that I found in this
place was that there was a beer-drinking
trumpet playing rabbit that a magician
gave to John F Kennedy for Caroline and
he quickly riga stood it to this
hospital so that was the one funny story
that i found about this place is that
for a period of time they had a
beer-drinking trumpet playing rabbit I'm
gonna skip on by Fort Pitt casting just
because of time here that's in
Pittsburgh was basically doomed by a you
know a lot of strife between the the
labor and the management and just
destroyed the town in fact the last
thing that Fort Pitt was used for after
it closed was as an incinerator to burn
the houses of the workers that had lost
their jobs there you know pretty awful
Schenley High School
I'm also beat like I said I want to get
to a Q&A here so I'm gonna kind of
sprint through some of these generally
high school was one that was really
important to me because this was the
most expensive public school that was
ever built at the time it was the first
school to cost
over a million dollars it was called the
pride of Pittsburgh and they really were
proud of it it's a triangular footprint
so that is not camera trickery right
there that's what it looks like
basically you know it kind of had its
ups and downs as the year went on the
thing that really doomed it was that in
2002 they had this window replacement
that caused a lot of humidity in the
school which affected the plaster pieces
of plaster started falling out so then
they said okay well if we're gonna fix
that maybe we should fix the electrical
systems maybe we should fix the
mechanical systems maybe we should fix
the air systems and then they did and
you can see right here actually areas
where they patched it up and areas where
it has fallen off and then they did a
test where they basically discovered oh
there's a fairly high concentration of
asbestos in there so then all the sudden
it was really big concern and they're
getting to a point where they're
thinking this is something that we can't
really afford to do what's interesting
though is so they closed the school very
contentious communities really upset
about it because obviously why wouldn't
you be this was a huge investment in the
community in such a huge part of
people's lives later reports said that
the asbestos was actually vastly
overstated and this coal so very
interesting kind of weird sold for
condos I'm not saying that I think that
there was in what I read I don't
necessarily think that it was a case of
some sort of treacherous plot it was
just more it seemed like a bit of a
comedy of errors
you know and so this really great public
institution is lost to the public and
sold to the private however I will say
that the the developers have really been
all about retaining the character of the
building they seem like they're quite
nice people I've talked to them too
can't really blame them for the
situation that brought about the closure
so this place was closed in 2008 and if
you look now I mean one of the things
this is kind of a bigger by the way had
a brand-new auditorium when it closed
too one of the things that this I think
shows a larger example of Pennsylvania
schools are really in a perilous
position with the constant
budget crises you know and they're
always you know kind of having to borrow
money to keep the lights on and stuff
and there are a lot of schools that are
closing this is a huge problem in in in
Philadelphia as well but Pittsburgh is
struggling with it to the victory and
variety theaters are two different
theaters that are in Cleveland well no
wait a minute in Holyoke Massachusetts
that's where the victory is and the the
variety is in Cleveland and there are
these beautiful theaters and kind of
what this chapter was about was the
various reasons that they went out of
business over the years because you
really do have these kind of grand
theaters the variety was home to not
only a bunch of films over its time but
also a lot of musical acts they had some
really great groups they're like you
know Slayer and Motorhead Metallica and
REM and actually Motorhead was the one
that you know as legend has it played so
loud that plaster rained from the
ceiling and really this caused a lot of
problems in the community so it was shut
down due to noise complaints it operated
briefly after that is the Cleveland
Metro Wrestle plaques and then was
closed and the thing that it shares in
common with the Victory Theatre in
Massachusetts is they both were I mean
the victory theater was one of the
richest cities per capita in the u.s.
they had all these mills and all these
immigrants coming in at like 7 different
theaters there you know and both of them
were in pretty affluent areas that just
kind of took a nosedive I mean in the
Victory's case although all the mills
just went south right out the bottom of
the country and so you have this area
that suddenly is very poor and they
actually lost a lot of their
architectural heritage during the urban
renewal period not because they were
rebuilding but because people were
burning the buildings for insurance so
the group that has this and the group
that has the other theater both of them
are fighting these kind of tooth and
nail battles and the theaters represent
a revitalization of their area I mean
one of the things that people often
forget is that Broadway was basically
pardon me for just a moment here the
theatres on Broadway were once
endangered
in the 60s and 70s and so there were a
lot of them that were torn down and at
that point they're like adult theater
adult theaters they had peep shows
things like that but now you know
because they've been revitalized in 2012
to 2013 they sustained 87 thousand jobs
and generated eleven point nine billion
dollars so you know it's not just this
pipe dream that these towns are really
hoping that by bringing the theaters
back it'll start generating some economy
in that area and that's why it's very
important to them the SS United States
again I'm going to kind of sprint
through here quick but this was the
fastest ocean liner
ever built it was basically said to go
between 38 and 44 knots so approximately
44 miles an hour it was also the largest
liner built on US soil it's it's just
about a hundred feet longer than the
Titanic you have celebrities that were
on it such as end presidents including
JFK Clinton Eisenhower Truman John Wayne
Elizabeth Taylor Marlon Brando Judy
Garland Grace Kelly I could keep going
on and on there are a lot of them so and
this is really only between 1952 and
1969 which were the years that it was in
use after it was out of use it was a big
problem because it was full of asbestos
the owner or the the guy who designed it
William Gibbs was terrified of fire and
one of the reasons was the infamous
Morro Castle fire which if you haven't
heard about that oh my god read about it
it's the most terrifying thing so you
get an idea that he would fill this up
with asbestos so that you know that same
thing wouldn't happen to this ship so
after it was decommissioned there is
this big sort of that they were trying
to take it to different ports nobody
wanted anything to do with it or all the
asbestos they finally took it and gutted
it so right now you know you have an
intact exterior but the interior is
really pretty barren by the way a fun
thing this is little Canada Goose here
and that's it's Canada Goose friend
right there watching out it's kind of a
sassy thing but anyway you look at
interiors like this there are a lot
people out there that say well this is
kind of a rust bucket we should sink it
for a reef you know they'd never be able
to get that back
I would I would beg to differ it's
actually in a really good structural
condition and the fact that the interior
has been gutted would put it in a pretty
good condition for rehabilitating it
crystal Cruz recently optioned it you
know and basically said they were going
to pay the mooring fees for it and then
ultimately decided that they weren't
going to restore it as they had hoped so
the the Conservancy that owns it now is
sort of back to square one
you know in terms of trying to figure
out where to go with it but it's it's
one of those things that if you ever go
down you know by Ikea you see it across
there and it's gorgeous that's one of
two that are left so we will move along
to vulture City vulture city was the
most profitable mine in Arizona's
history it ran from 1863 to 1942 and is
said to generate anywhere between 30 and
200 million in gold so there's basically
the smaller gold rush in Arizona after
the one in California and you know the
the thing that you really read about
with this and again I'm gonna kind of
skim over a little bit with this but
that was that was really kind of
interesting is just you know reading
these old miners newspapers from the
late 1800s you know and and hearing
these stories about the the Native
American raids and such you know and you
really think wow why would they do that
you know that sounds so scary for them
and then you basically read that you
know from 1845 to 1870 about 80% of the
Native American population were
slaughtered and so when there was the
gold rush in California for example you
know the state actually paid bounties
for the scalps of Native American men
women and children so when this started
to move over to Arizona and these same
people are showing up and diverting
their water and messing with the herds
and displacing people you know I'm sure
that they were quite scared as they
really should have been you know cuz
that was that was really kind of a
terrible thing this mind caused a lot of
bloodshed and actually the one thing to
by the way it helped fund the foundation
of Phoenix Arizona
but anyway the guy who found it was sort
of swindled out of it and wound up
committing suicide so it's kind of a you
know a dark story but interesting
because you would think if you found
like this great mine that had all this
gold in it that life would just be
wonderful forever you know but not so
much so the last one here and then we'll
go to a quick QA is Gary Indiana Gary is
not you know it's a town it's a town in
which 78,000 people live in so you know
calling it abandoned really is unfair
however basically you know it's lost
about a hundred thousand people since
1960 and in a 2015 survey there were
13,000 blighted properties there which
is over a third over a third of the
structures that are there so it's sort
of like a little mini Detroit in that
sense I mean you just drive around and
it's block after block after block after
block of these places and you know I
think one of the things that's really
important when you view these places is
not you know just this sort of let's
take this in the aesthetics of it wow it
sure is neat to see ruins I mean you're
looking at real losses for real people
these are 78,000 people that live in a
community that is falling apart like
this and sort of the ruins of what was
once a great town and there are a lot of
reasons that you know this town is going
through this I think one of the biggest
ones is just the overall collapse of
steel
you know the Gary Works plant that was
there started to decline at about the
same time that a lot of other ones like
Bethlehem Steel and homestead did and a
big part of the reason for that was
because after World War Two we were kind
of the the main person out there the
main country out there that was a it was
producing steel but as other countries
rebuild they had more modern facilities
and we weren't modernizing our own so
American Steel couldn't really keep up
so the jobs left you know there was a
lot of racial strife in this town this
city had Richard Hatcher was one of the
first african-american mayors of like a
large city and he was actually really
blamed for a lot of what
and here which I personally think is I
mean I don't know if he was a great
mayor or not you know I've read about
him and that's one of those things it's
so polarized that it's hard to pull it
apart but stepping back from the whole
you know you love him you hate him stuff
I mean objectively the steel industry
was collapsing at that point objectively
the you know a lot of the white
businesses said you know what we're done
we're leaving and they pulled out to the
suburbs and the whole places economy
just collapsed it was really I mean for
a while it was a melting pot of
immigrants and you know but it was also
kind of a KKK stronghold so you really
had a lot of conflict and at the point
where that happened it just really
devastated the town this is something
where you're seeing you know the effects
of this kind of thing all across the
u.s. though particularly the
deindustrialization but you know these
had these really just grand
you know grand buildings there that is
the Memorial Auditorium and that's just
the front the back is burned off there
was a great fire that basically
destroyed that but Sinatra performed
there this was the town where the
Jackson 5 hailed from - but anyway in
1993 Gary was called the the murder
capital of the United States it had
three times the murder rate of Chicago
crime is still not great there it's
losing cops to other communities that
are safer and pay better and I think
really in a lot of ways this is their
post office by the way it represents our
kind of a modern crisis which is finding
an identity in a way to move forward
when the things that that created a town
that sustained a town are gone where do
you go from there you know you kind of
can't just leave the whole place fall
apart and become this third world
country but what are the alternatives so
I think it's really important that we
look at it and address it not just out
of respect for the residents that are
there but also you know for ourselves in
our own cities and I'm going to kind of
leave on this this was sort of the the
last image that I ended the book on and
what really stood out to me was just you
know when I went he
and I kind of looked at that for about
10 minutes and I was just looking at all
the faces of all the kids that went to
one of the schools and the schools were
really one of the big you know kind of
the pride of Gary you know and you just
think about all these kids that went to
this this close school and then went out
into this community where they don't
have jobs they don't have safety they
don't necessarily have Economic
Opportunity or a way to leave they're
there they're in a place that's in ruins
and when you look at the you know the
the people's faces it really kind of
drives home the human cost of all of
this but again I mean there are people
that are still out there that are decent
people that live there and work there
and are trying to make the place better
and for the bad reputation that it has
everybody that I met there was actually
really terrific you know but anyway so
that is basically the presentation on my
book and if you get a moment and look at
this the one thing you can really do to
help if you enjoy the book is reviews
reviews are so important you know on
Amazon Barnes & Noble Goodreads that is
a huge huge help so anyway with that
thank you so much for coming and I'd
love to take your questions and if you
will when you ask a question if you just
wait for a moment for them to get the
the boom mic over you thank you so much
[Applause]
any questions oh just a sec have any of
your place that you visit and fixed up
have you gone back to see them fixed up
or has any but not gets the board
flipped that you've gone back revisited
yeah actually I mean there have been
quite a few places that have been
restored the majority of not I mean the
majority are either still abandoned or
have been torn down but absolutely there
are a number of places
Schenley would be a good example of one
you know the theatres are a good example
where they're in the process of trying
to do that now the game farm they're
trying to sort of build that back up but
there are absolutely places in fact
there there places that you wouldn't
even know of in your community that are
kind of the gems for example the Ellis
Island Museum you know you would go in
that and not necessarily ever think that
was an abandoned site but more to the
point in what you're asking if I've been
to particular places like that yes I I
have there have been there have been
quite a few and it really is heartening
to see I think one of the neatest things
is kind of being able to photograph the
you know the before and after with that
and for example one of the other places
the Elk Lodge is a little bit different
in that they tore the building down but
I just got a you know an email from the
developer of that that had torn it down
and is using it actually unbeknownst to
me saved quite a few of the
architectural features and is using them
in the building that they're putting in
that place and invited me up to see it
so it's going to be pretty neat kind of
going to see where all of the things
that they saved from the building are
going in thank you
just as a from an artistic perspective
do you do anything to the sights before
you photograph them any staging of
things or do you just kind of do it as
you find it I don't like the staged
things I I personally think that that's
kind of cheating I like to leave things
as I find them so that's not to say that
somebody else may not have you know
moved a chair out into a hallway or
something you know there are certainly
ones where the idea of a place being a
time capsule I think is kind of a bit of
a myth if you find a place like that
it's it's quite rare you know they are
out there and I've been to a few but
usually you have people that move things
around here there but I don't
particularly care for doing it the one
thing that I would do and I don't really
feel bad about this is like let's say
that somebody's thrown a water bottle or
something you know like because that
isn't really a part of what the building
is or the authenticity of it you know
things like that where somebody just
throws some trash on the floor
I don't feel too bad about moving that
but no I don't I don't particularly like
you know staging a shot because it just
feels a little like inauthentic to me
any other questions it seems that there
ought to be some kind of deterrence to
this happening are there any communities
that don't allow the abandonment of
these beautiful structures and do you
know it's blight you know
I think you know I think that it's kind
of a community by community thing and
it's also a decade by decade thing mayor
by mayor thing you know so for example I
mean you know you have places like
Niagara Falls New York where they raised
a huge chunk of the downtown during the
the urban renewal period but then I just
presented in Salem University in North
Carolina and that's like this gorgeously
preserved town that they are very very
very protective of the historic
character I think as we go on that's
going to be something that's going to be
increasingly important and increasing
drawed I mean if you look if any of you
guys are preservation minded folks
Philadelphia we're always fighting that
battle and I hate to say but
preservation loses a lot to money it
loses a lot and we have lost a lot of
treasures here but I think in the long
term what you really see is that those
places that define an area are what draw
people to an area I mean why go to a
place if it's just the same Walmart's
and condos and you know Applebee's that
you can go to anywhere else so you know
I think there are a number of
communities where they really have that
sort of foresight and they're trying to
preserve those things and typically
that's a really good investment for them
but there are a lot of other places and
again I mean you know I hate to say it
but I think Philadelphia is going
through a real low in the last at least
10 years or so in terms of just
demolishing places that they have no
right I mean you know the jeweller's Row
is kind of the big fight of the moment
that you know they're looking at
leveling that and you know some of the
buildings there and making condos and
that's just kind of a big back and forth
so to answer your question it'd be hard
to pick you know town by town historic
designation by historic designation it's
just something that it seems like
there's not really a particularly
cohesive plan it's just something this
area fights in success is successful
this area fights and they lose so just a
second yeah
at this stage in your career our
building owners fairly open to letting
you come in or is it a tough battle to
get into it is it is a lot of work even
I mean I'm lucky that I think I have a
bit more cachet than I did when I first
started I have like two books now so I
can kind of wave that around you know I
mean I can't really over the phone but
you know what I mean
so that is something that helps but it's
still not easy I mean it still is one of
those things where you really have kind
of feast or famine period so for example
my sister actually contacted Randall
Park Mall on my behalf she was helping
me kind of do some work on that and the
owner was familiar with with my
photography and had seen it in an
article and you know kind of wanted to
have me up great that was so easy you
know I ran right up there to try and do
it before he changed his mind
places like the Catskill game farm you
know where were ones where I had just a
really good easy time doing that the
owners were really nice then there were
places like the SS United States where
you know that was extraordinarily
difficult I mean this is pre conservancy
days when Norwegian owned it you know so
and at this point I mean I still I would
say if when I started off if I had five
to ten percent success rate that was
really great you know and now maybe I
have like 15 to 20 percent success rate
so it's better but it's still a lot of
work and a lot of failures and you know
a lot a lot of heartache when you put a
lot of work into a place and really hope
to see it you don't get too
you you would ask if liability was the
big concern I think that is one of the
concerns but sometimes people don't care
about that I mean they might say well
you know liability and we're worried
about that and you say okay well I have
insurance I can get you a certificate
they're like oh that was just a thing I
was telling you to say no you know so I
mean the other thing to that is there's
a lot more interest in these places and
that's been really problematic I think
for a lot of property owners it's been
really problematic so there have been
places that have been torn down because
of so many people breaking into them at
least that was one of the reasons that
they brought up for it and so I think
particularly with the interest we passed
the point where it used to be that you
know you would be in a place say you're
you know you wonder onto a property and
you're taking pictures of it and the
days of your you know you you might run
into a property owner and they might say
oh how quaint and odd that you are
interested in taking pictures of this
old building you know that's really
strange but somewhat endearing so I'll
let you go do that whereas now I think
people are used to people sneaking into
places and taking pictures and there is
a very real concern about theft
vandalism arson
you know liability so I think there's
also a lot less tolerance for that too I
think that they're you know they view
people that are interested in the places
is somewhat of a drain on their
resources and time and a threat and so
can be pretty difficult but yeah it's
that's a case-by-case basis I can take
one more did we have one more question
sure
I grew up right around where White Marsh
Hall used to be and I think they
demolished him when I was two and it's
one of those places I wish I had been
able to just sort of explore around are
there any places like that for you oh
there are so many places like that there
are so many places that I wish I were
able to get to and I would love to go to
I mean I think the the really big thing
that I'd like to do in the years to come
is kind of to explore more abroad
because I just see these gorgeous
pictures of places that have a whole
different timeline you know 15 century
chateaus or you know places that are
hospitals that have been around for
centuries that I'd love to get to so I
think the the big thing is to go to
Europe and beyond as sort of what I'd
like to do in the future
so with that thank you again all so much
for being here I hope you'll join me out
there for the reception and I really
appreciate you spending your time with
me this Friday evening thank you
[Applause]